me personally it's more about a degree
of
personality traits alongside Beauty I
think the things what people have uh
what women think matter to Men actually
don't we don't care about your money we
don't care that you're independent we
don't care you are a quote-unquote boss
[ __ ] like no one cares about any of
that things especially if you want
something seriously I think the biggest
thing they don't understand is that
the to get a man to commit to you and to
get a man to sleep with you is different
and those qualities are different so if
a guy is just looking to sleep with a
woman
um certain long-term things he won't be
interested in
um so for me I would say
why what women need to bring or what I
would like them to bring per se is sort
of feminine energy submissive
non-argumentative
um kind
of supportive these are the traits are
important to me anyway
um for me personally I'd say
I would like in a serious relationship a
woman to bring loyalty is a big one for
me
um
and I'd also say
apart from loyalty another big one would
be
if I had to be virtuous
I'd say
to be virtuous and what do you mean by
virtuous virtuous is
not in the sense of almost like a
that kind of
innocent feminine energy and
unwillingness to kind of
take leadership are you Christian uh no
I wouldn't trust myself as Christian
have you heard of proverbs 31. I've
heard of it I don't know what it is
that's why it's describing the ideal
wife I think proverbs 31 is probably the
best example of a virtuous woman but
it's a it's intimidating yes but yeah
that's what women should strive to be I
would agree with you
yeah
so me do you do you date hoes
[Laughter]
so me what I would like my woman to
bring to the table is loyalty I would
need my my woman to be my friend because
I don't just want to be with someone
that's not that I don't get along with
and again like she would need to be
beautiful in a sense because I don't
just want to be looking at you and like
you don't like I'm not attracted to you
so that would be for me
well for me definitely you'd have to be
a virgin so virginity is the main thing
I'd say come you're born with value
don't give it away if you want the guy
to full on marry devote to you and make
you his one and only don't give away
what makes you valuable to men you're
born with a certain amount of value
based on your looks based on your Purity
but even sometimes based on your family
status sometimes you're from a wealthy
family well-known family there's a lot
of things that go into it but yeah I'd
say the main things are definitely
submission you want you don't want
someone to argue against you you don't
want someone to be against you you want
to be the leader of your house you want
to be the leader of the relationship and
in order to do that you need someone
submissive loyalty is definitely there
because if she's not loyal no one's
going to be interested in her in the
first place unless you're you know a car
core a simple who knows there's loads of
words to describe feminine definitely
because you know it's just you can't be
masculine and expect a masculine man
because a masculine man is going to want
someone feminine you can't be because
it's the same way of describing a man
who's part feminine and like one day he
wants to wear a mini skirt or a dress
that's not very masculine is it it's
like a woman saying oh yeah I'm gonna
wear the trousers and go to work today
it's just like that's not feminine it's
just it's not what men want
men literally want feminine loyalty
submission Purity Beauty as well like
some men don't even expect that much
Beauty anymore they've actually got lots
as long as you're hitting the other
targets they're actually fine with
lowering what they perceive as their
level
as long as you hit everything else that
they want so that's what I'd say they
should actually bring to the table what
they've already got what they're born
with and then character traits that they
just develop over time if they're
actually following what they should be
following
um I want a woman that's Cooperative
again no one likes to argue all day
um a woman that's submissive
um she knows that I'm not being not
asking her to be submissive is not
against her it's all that everything
runs smoothly
um a woman as a team player that
understands that everything is for the
betterment of the collective not for
anyone's selfish interests and the woman
that's supportive kind
yeah that's that's about it
well uh if I'm just looking for a good
time then
none of what anyone here is
um apart from you know you gotta look
good of course
but if it's um someone I'm gonna take
seriously
um you have to just not get in the way
of my work
you've got to
add
to my work ethic as in whatever you can
do whatever holes you can feel that I
may have that can help me
um do what I do better
uh you know help me in my kind of
my strive for more
my ambition
so just get behind me and support me
and be loyal
be in shape
and if you're not in shape then you must
have that
um as a goal you must be actively right
now be looking to get into shape
and
yeah just be you know just just be cool
like
you know all that loudness and relative
to none of that just
be cool be feminine
are there any skills that you'd like
like what specific skills would you like
a girl to have
but it's cook would be nice okay what
what do you think girls should be able
to cook
um I don't think pasta counts I'm gonna
start I think everyone is like I said I
wanna I wanna be wifey like what what
should she what should she start with
what did she learn to cook uh cultural
food so depending on what ethnicity she
is I think she should at least know the
basic the basic foods that our culture
comes from if I'm with someone Arab I
expect them for example Moroccan I
expected tonight to make tagine I
expected to make the basic things that
come from that side of the world I'm
sure if I'm American I should know
hamburgers and hot dogs
there's brisket there's barbecue I've
seen American barbecue I know but like
I'm sure like I know I know some
Jamaican guys that's like if my wife
can't make rice and peas I'm not even
gonna look at her so this is you know
it's just you need to be able to provide
the sustenance side and like the
nurturing side so you need to be able to
cook you need to be able to clean
because that is the main thing you're
going to be doing it's like you're going
to be taking care of children
skills what cleaning skills would you
want you get to build a wife today
want to get specific because a lot of
times when I hear what guys want from
girls it's very Broad and there's no
like specific things that girls can do
to like train to do these things and we
are opening a wife school soon so oh
well I think the reason sorry the reason
why there's no specific things is
because if there were those girls would
not give a [ __ ] anyway
okay well today we're doing a whiteboard
no we'll care if we're into you well I
mean there's women that they find
themselves like surprised they're you
know turning out their feminine side I
guess for the right guy they find
themselves on Google looking up how to
make French toast so so it happens but I
think yeah there has to be genuine
desire so if a woman if a woman is just
giving you a hard time about the things
that you like well she can kind of just
keep it pushing I think that's a fair
point and the ability to learn as well
even if you don't know how to do
anything the ability to learn to show is
how I personally would receive care I
would that to me that would show you
that you care about what I think what I
like to do what I like to eat Etc and
the ability to learn is half the battle
but with the attitude of oh I don't want
to do that why should I do that it's
it's just redundant isn't it yeah yeah
that's how I got married I didn't know
how to do anything any I have no no
model of like how to be a wife but I
brought a willingness to learn and so I
think that that just happened to be
enough well with results because I feel
like I feel like if I was slipping up
people say something so I think it
really just comes down to the basics of
knowing how to keep a house so if the
man's actually going out working working
his ass off trying to provide for the
family I think that it's the women's
actual duty to make sure the house is
clean the kids are taken care of he
doesn't want to come home to everyone
screaming he wants like the house to be
peace he wants to come home to peace
from chaos work is sometimes chaos I
describe work it's chaos sometimes so
he's going to come from chaos into Peace
So the whole point is everything needs
to be kept dinner ready and that's it
it's it's not that difficult like I'd
say that when you talk about cleaning
skills I'd say just like mop mop floor
make it so that when you enter the house
you take off your shoes so the house
stays clean like everyone people in the
house makes try their hardest to make
sure it doesn't get any dirtier but
obviously the wife's job is to clean if
it does get any dirty so dusting just
mopping you know vacuum cleaner yeah
even get a room by it does half the job
you up for you but at the end of the day
the whole point is you just want to come
home to a nice clean nice smelling house
and I think to add on to the the Peace
point that you made I think a woman
should be like your spiritual protector
in a sense like you'll have physical
protector I feel like she needs to be
able to like Spirit spiritually protect
you and ground you because the world is
almost can be chaotic and when you come
home you want her to be able to ground
you and you want her to be able to make
you feel at peace if that makes sense
and that goes back to our point about we
don't want someone argumentative yeah
destructive those things don't bring
peace and ironically what happens is if
you are with a woman like that and she
behaves like that that's just in all
honesty it just gives a man more reason
to cheat because he's just gonna go
somewhere and build up peace
understanding you know good listening
skills from another woman and she's
going to set your place as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible